انسحاب بروسيا المفاجاه من خرسون افسح
المجال للحديث عن اتفاقنا مبطن بين موسكو
وواشنطن بهدف اعطاء فرصه امام المفاوضات
بل بما قد ايحقق السلام ويجنب العالم
تصعيد النويا الحلفاء الغربيون وان عبروا
عن التزامهم بمواصله تقدم الدعم لاوكرانيا
الا ان الاصوات التي تطالب بالدفع نحو
السلام بين المسؤولين الامريكيين
العسكريين قبل الدكتوماسيين لما تعد سريه
بل ان الصين ايضا الصوره ايضا والعهد على
المكرونه
قائد الاركان العامه الامريكيه ورغم
المكاسب الاوكرانيه على الارض الا انه
استبعد تحقيق الطرفين الى نصرا ساحق يضمن
انهاء الحرب ولهذا السبب طالب باللجوء الى
وسائل اخرى جبهه اخرى ديكلوماسيه عبر
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جاكسون الذي
نقل رساله من دارت بيضا الى زينسكي في
الرابع من الشهر الجاري نص الرساله كان
واضحا على كيف قبول المفاوضات من اجل
الحصول على مزيدنا من التعاطف الدوليه فكر
بواقعيه في الاولويات هكذا كشفت صحيفه
ولسجنن عن مطالبه السالفه والحديث هنا
تحديدا عن رغبه زيلانس كيف استعاده شبه
جزيره القرم واشنطن التي دعمت وحدها كييف
بما يصل الى 20 مليار دولار لا تتخشن
هياره مخزون لها من الاسلحه في ظل حرب
الاستنزاف طويله الامد وبالتالي
والمفاوضات حل مثالي استرجاعه خرسانه كان
شرطا اساسيا على نازله ان المفاوضات لن
تتم بدونه لكنه الان وان ما ما دين ملكيه
المعارك الجديده قد يرغب في تحقيق اقصى
استفاده منها
رغبه انها عقد تجعله يضع شروطنا للتفاوض
غير واقعيه تماما كما تحدث سالبا
[موسيقى]
ديسكو وينستون